honestly like we lament those students
understand free speech long part of my
argument is have we done a good job of
explaining I have Nicolas be with reason
TV and today we're talking with Greg
lukianov he is the president of fire the
foundation for individual rights in
education and he's also an executive
producer of can we take a joke a great
documentary about politics political
correctness and campus speech Greg
thanks for talking to us
hi family let's talk first about the
campus situation there was a bizarre
circumstance at Williams College yeah
talk about yeah that was particularly
oppressing now I have to say this has
been one of the worst years for campus
free speech that I've seen in my entire
career and I'm and then that is my
entire career but this situation you
know it's kind of typical to a degree
but it was a black liberal student who
had a program called uncomfortable
learning which by the way I've spoken at
at Williams want to invite John
Derbyshire who among his other
accomplishments has also written some
fairly racist materials he's a former
National Review writer who's now at
hockey mag and crossed the line a couple
years ago and has kind of been written
out of polite society yeah and and he
got fired from National Review for some
fraud you wrote so this is a black
student African American student who
wants to invite John Derbyshire to
debate at uncomfortable learning and
he's overruled by the white president of
Williams saying that John Derbyshire
could not be allowed on campus and the
idea is like but are you missing the
context of that you're actually going to
have a student who wants to want to
actually take this guy on one on one
well that's a case at least where the
student is actually kind of sticking up
for if not Derbyshire views free speech
or in exchange a dialog yep talk about
Emery and yeah what what does the Emery
incident with the chalk chalking for
Donald Trump yes about what's really
true Emrys kind of funny because it's
one of these cases worried about people
at fire were like oh well you know big
because of what happened is someone
wrote Trump 2016
and there were protests and there was
you know there were claims that people
were demanding therapy and people are
claiming that wasn't really true but it
made national news
where as as far as fire was concerned
this is just another day in the office
but I think the mistake that was made
was but was the pride
came out and said listen we're gonna be
reviewing the closed-circuit TVs we're
gonna be reviewing all the tapes to
figure out who this vandal was who did
this chalking of Trump 26 2016 which and
that's what got us concerned because
we're like no you're not gonna punish
this person for talking because you
don't like the roadie what he was
expressing you've also talked about how
one of the things that's different now
is that in the past it used to be it was
the administrators who were kind of
forcing speech coats on kids or on
students and now it's students almost
forcing the administrators to shut
people down where did that come from and
what does that mean for the future I
don't entirely know where it came from
but you know fires was found in 99 I
started in 2001 and for the overwhelming
majority of my career what I've been
fighting his administrative overreach
then the other phase was that the the
feds really started pushing
administrators to overreach so it was
this horrible cycle but during that
entire time the single constituency on
campus that seemed to have the most
common sense and understand free speech
and even due process the best was always
the students and somewhere two or three
years ago it just kind of changed right
around the dis invitation season time
you co-wrote with Jonathan Hite the
social psychologists at NYU a great
piece for the Atlantic magazine called
the coddling of the American mind is
that what's happening we're seeing the
full flowering of this kind of bubble
bubble wrap protection that is to be
completely Frank we really don't know
and I'd love to do a lot more research
on it but I think that honestly that
there's there's a freedom speech is a
really sophisticated concept we're so
used to it in America that we kind of
forget how sophisticated it is meanwhile
if you have a K through 12 environment
or a parental environment when people
are explaining all free speech that's
just the argument the bully the bigot
and the robber baron make that's morally
persuasive and if nobody's ever
explained to you otherwise then of
course you're going to think that free
speech is is is the mean diamine
person's argument well and that brings
us to can we take a joke the documentary
that was directed by Ted baliker former
reason employer and it was done with
some reason TV helped as well this is a
movie about how political correctness
and stand-up comedy are kind of oil and
water
talk about the incident that actually
prompted the the genesis of the movie
so a funny thing well I came out with a
book in 2012 called unlearning liberty
and I got invited to a lot of shows but
the most impressive the one that I
thought was the coolest was I got
invited to do a podcast at the Comedy
Cellar with the owner of the Comedy
Cellar who just thought I was absolutely
right and there was a comedian on the
panel with me and he kept on talking
about him being like the most liberal
person on the panel and about being a
liberal comedian and towards the end of
the interview he said I don't really
like playing campuses anymore because I
can't use my good material and that to
me it made sense to me already by that
time but I was really striking to hear
that from a liberal comedian and since
then we've heard Jerry Seinfeld Elmar
and Chris Rock all say similar things
what is the you know why should why
should students see can we take a joke
and why should all the rest of us say
well the first reason is because it
actually it's incredibly funny we got
Gilbert Gottfried in it we got Penn
Jillette we got Lisa Lampanelli we got
Adam Carolla the movie itself is great
we also have the great Jonathan Roush
isn't it and it's also my attempt to
sort of trick people into learning about
freedom of speech so we make that we
make the point that Lenny Bruce the much
venerated comedian from the 60s wouldn't
last for five minutes on the modern
college campus and sometimes people like
oh of course he would it's like no no
look at his actual routines he really
really wouldn't have
so we paralleled the career of Lenny
Bruce and make the point that we're
creating a culture on campus now if you
have a right to be offended you can't
really have comedy and the movie was
recently bought by Samuel Goldwyn so
it's going to be appearing in theaters
over the summer yeah at least LA or New
York hopefully other places that's great
what is the besides more speech is there
a solution to kind of the the tightening
of the clamp on free speech well you
know the thing that we need to do that
we haven't tried well enough is that
honestly like we lament those students
understand free speech well part of my
argument is have we done a good job of
explaining it and when people point out
when I asked them well though what's the
good book that to teach you about
freedom of speech you know the first
book that comes to most people's mind
was written in 1859 and it's it's on
Liberty and that's the same year as
Origin of Species so I've been working
really hard to break the the components
of freedom speech down into tiny tiny
little chunks to explain why it's
arrogant to be
a sensor about why the simple habits
like if we just got back to an idea of
it's important to hear opposing points
of view it's important to give the
benefit of the doubt if your
intellectual you should consider a duty
to seek out smart people with whom you
disagree we could do a lot to combat
this trend